we are going to talk about we happy few
which is in early access now on xbox one
and pc don't know a ton about this game
really despite the fact that we've seen
kind of a lot of gameplay now which is
weird that a lot of us didn't know a lot
about yeah so Jamie brought you and
because you were on the stream with
jean-luc this morning right yes I've
actually been playing a lot of it this
weekend and it is definitely not what I
think people were expecting I'm sure if
you were like following this close
enough you probably would have known
that there were roguelike aspects to
this to this game but as someone or SP
because people just kind of saw it at e3
people probably gonna be surprised
because it's not at least not yet it's
not story heavy okay so can you tell me
like what the demo encompasses I should
doesn't it it starts with like what we
saw the e3 it says yes with that we like
Bioshock ask like brave new world I
guess like to be a literary snob the
kind of Aldous Huxley like they take the
drug called joy here we go you're like
equilibrium which is less that's like
more of like a dude bro action movie
with Christian Bale stops taking the
drug he's a grandson cleric I know you
know I know I know you glue so you know
the movie yeah no it's it's a it's just
the same conceit right there it's like a
dystopia we're like emotions are banned
or no in this case the same things like
yes so everyone needs to be happy yeah
and you have to take a pill every so
often then I didn't go into specifics
talk to you take it but every time you
take it then things look brighter and
happier and you see rainbows and things
like that but in the intro which is kind
of interesting you can decide to take
the pill or not to take the pill if you
take the pill the game ends if you don't
take the pill then it goes through that
intro that they showed at e3 which is
really cool um it really sets the sets
the mood for the game it seems very
story driven at that point but once you
get out of that you're kind of just
dropped in a randomly generated world
and you're kind of left to survive their
emissions to follow their quest to do
but there isn't much of a story yet
they're supposed to be three though
three different characters in three
different stories eventually Oh
interesting cuz ya like what it
immediately strikes me as a survival
kind of like roguelike game what's going
on here hutchins crazy lady is what kick
well that's what i did i played i think
it was like pax prime last year
first played this like an Xbox showcase
and I remember playing and just like
these six people chased me into a house
and I was beating him away with clubs
for about 10 minutes because that's all
I had and then I started punching them I
I think I died so that happens yeah
that's I did that happen a lot of the
stream no I died once on the stream but
it was hot can you go more into detail
about the survival elements like how no
is there like first or anything that's
it like deep or is it kind of just
though so cursory it's not super deep
it's you have to drink water you eat
food you have to sleep those are the
things and then you can get sick you can
get the plague actually in like you can
also get sick too so not just in the
plague if you like rotten food you're
gonna get sick actually one of the ways
i'd i'd actually was that I got sick I
started puking and I puked up anything I
ate anything I drank until I starve and
uh i starved to death and I like thirst
to death what is that she died of thirst
he drank too much water that was thirst
to death is yeah but that's that's like
a water poisoning h2o pretty much too
what's the joke a guy walks into a bar
still have an h2o second guy walks in
all of an h2o two second guy dies what
is it hydrogen peroxide a chemist joke I
hang out a lot of chemists you do yeah
but ya know so we happy few people were
talking before this about how like I
again none of us know like how like the
overall veins of the game like what it
completely how it's gonna play through
like as you're like going from beginning
to end or dying and restarting and
whatnot but you know there's kind of
been this resurgence of rogue lights I
guess in the last like five years or so
cuz like smaller teams can make them i
guess like you know hello games dunno
man sky is 12 people or they made no
man's sky it's 12 people and they're
kind of you know there's algorithms
allow them to make bigger games without
like certain assets and whatnot I don't
know is this kind of game this game
specifically interest you but also like
are you kind of interested in rogue
lights in general no I'm not all right I
was eight you know when they first
showed this game i was totally
interested in the narrative you know
concept and i played a demo that was
definitely packed with like more
characters and
sort of like action-oriented moments but
then watching your stream and watching
this game play right now and you know it
doesn't seem to communicate very strong
identity of like what the world is just
in the wandering and gathering and fist
fighting Crazy Legs like I don't I don't
really get a lot out of that so I'm not
seeing a game that really interests me
at the moment okay knotted the survival
games either probably that nonsensically
I don't gravitate towards them I mean if
you want to consider fallout a survival
game like sure I like fallout but I
don't play like you know what was I one
starve don't starve I don't don't starve
yeah I didn't play stressful game I
don't play stuff like that I guess so it
is considerably less stressful and don't
starve look um in like you I'm actually
not that interested in these kind of
games either but I did kind of stick
with it it took a while but it's
actually like I think it does have an
identity I think it they're still kind
of trying to figure some of the details
out maybe yeah but I think I think a lot
of people like will enjoy this even if
you don't like roguelikes because it's
not you're not gonna be dying constantly
it's not like trying to be challenging
and in a sense it's more it's more about
that exploration and like your goal is
to escape basically yeah i'm at least
from this so like each area you get to
there's new things that kind of help you
put put you towards that goal to get to
joy town i think is what it's called
Wellington anyway but it's where
everyone's really happy and if you don't
look happy that the cops'll yeah beat
the crap out of you it's not so much
that I don't like the the inherent
stress of survival it's how you can
attach yourself to that world and
whether it's fun to play or not so I'm
looking at this I'm not seeing something
that looks particularly fun if survival
is the only thing and I don't know it
just doesn't do it for me yeah I mean I
hope I mean I hope that eventually maybe
they'll add something where you can kind
of turn those things off and just have a
more story focused game especially when
they add it add that story mode or main
quest yeah if there's a story mode I'm
in like I'll do that I guess yeah I mean
just because like it's fun but it gets
annoying after a while and like there
are water fountains like so often it's
like what why is this even a problem
like if I just step outside drink water
and then I'm fine like it right
hoard food yeah well the food's a little
tougher to come by but there are humans
walking everywhere that's true you can
human how how fast you that you'd resort
to cannibalism if something like this
went down immediately yeah I've been
waiting she's gonna be here right now
yeah it's like the road that creepy
scene where they go to the basement and
viggo video Morgenstein finds all the
people in the face and they've just
sprint out using that movie I was
talking about earlier the witness really
the Amish people moving on yeah we've
you sent me a lot of weird movie
recommendations today I didn't holy
mountain I didn't recommend on witness
movies you recommended the Blair Witch
to I still watch that oh don't watch
that incidentally there's Blair Witch
three anyway we're kind of getting off
track with viggo in the air yeah that's
just I'm just trying to morph this into
my podcast that's the thing there's you
know you're saying there's three
branching storylines it's just early
access right now so who knows what's
gonna happen the developers said their
plan is to keep it in early access for 6
to 12 months it doesn't have a full
release day from what I understand it's
on you know steam xbox one right now
yeah i i'm not sure what the release
date is i'm not sure if the release
schedule is they could have talked about
it I haven't looked into it I to be
honest I wish they didn't do early
access for this I wish they'd just
waited and kind of like finished more
cuz this game is also really buggy to
like last night I was playing a save I
was by like three hours in and I got
stuck in geometry and that was it like I
just starved to death there so so you
would have lost and don't starve there
yeah dude you would have that you just
hunched over in the middle of that scene
it's super weird moving like I sick the
thing that drew me into the game at
first was the art style the aesthetic
they're going for with this kind of you
know this like it looks like the English
countryside right this dystopia
Wellington joy town which one is it I
don't was the same place I think they're
the same place okay uh it just it it
strikes me something I wanted to play
just based on like the characters masks
kind of had that weird like a rapture
from bioshock feel ya that trailer
during the microsoft press conference at
e3 hooked me because it was you know
it's like this you just don't take the
drug and i'll send it flashes and
instead of a pinata was it you're
stabbing a rat or something so that
that's really cool that was cool that's
the intro to this that is the interest
that's what people will see I still
don't think people should roll it out
that they don't like road bikes because
I think I think this story could be
really cool but
we don't know yeah I'm it remains to be
seen whether you know it's an early
access I doubt they would just throw all
the narrative stuff at you for the next
six to 12 months or whatever they plan
to be an early access with but I don't
know it's it seems like maybe they don't
they haven't shown how they're going to
marry the narrative experience with the
actual like overarching survival rogue
light elements yeah and I think that's
going to put a lot of people off and I
think that's why I kind of wish this was
an early access because a lot of people
were expecting like a more narrative
game and I think now people looking like
oh this isn't this isn't narrative I
don't know if I'm interested in this
anymore do you don't you don't plan on
playing it much more in early access um
I'll played again I think when there's
more story to it because what I have
played I have enjoyed I like most of my
problems with it like once I get used to
that world or just like little things
like I like glitches like getting stuck
in geometry that sucks but then like the
the map you have to pull your map like
every couple seconds and they have a
compass probably see it in the house
just inventory house like the user
interface because a lot of times in
survival games that's kind of a tough
thing to navigate and Tori kind of sucks
yeah um it's not streamlined yeah it's
not super streamlined but yeah i mean
the the compass like it doesn't show
where things are so you're constantly
checking your map which is kind of a
pain in the butt but i don't know i
recommend people giving it a try i heard
somewhere to that if you get it on xbox
one you can try the first hour free okay
um so if you're on the fence maybe give
it a shot yeah they just stigma attached
to early access I feel like has so many
times people with like you're worried
that they're not going to deliver on the
promise right like some games get an
early access and stay there for what
like two years isn't it kind of like I
forget the percentage of games that go
into early access and never make it out
it's staggering and I'm hoping like this
game intrigued me especially after the
microsoft press conference with that
kind of like you know brave new world
stuff was really interesting to me and I
I do want it for the narrative but I
suppose you guys I really like survival
like roguelike games I'd love don't
starve it's stressful as hell I'm really
like this then I think I'll try it out
like I'm mean to I just I need to figure
out when I'm gonna find time because I
those are games you kind of want to
really dig into but I don't know check
it out definitely for sure but thanks
for sharing your experience of the
stream and uh he doesn't sound like
you're jumping back in well I'll try
out I'll check out we have a few the
title itself is really good it's like
part of a sentence like the last of us
it's just ominous part of it yeah no
it's not like it's like a we happy few
like were they talking about no are they
talking about you know the last of us is
just weird sentence fragment alright
anyway that's that so we have helped you
early access on xbox one pc no idea when
it's going to be fully out sometime the
next year maybe next year next year's in
cuz it's early access maybe never but
yeah so go try it out you get download
it there and come back to get you spot
for you no more coverage on that